this one comes from
manual 1723 what team that finished
fourth in its division last season could
win the division this upcoming season
and frankly he added the plural in there
so it could be more than one team big
cat do you have one or more teams that
finished in last place that could pull
off the worst to first resurrection
okay i'm looking at it right now um and
it's gonna be tough it's gonna be tough
um all right so i'll actually here's
here's i'll give you two the cardinals
the cardinals i think are going trending
in the right direction it seems like
they've got
kyle murray is going to be one of those
guys who makes that big leap into the
second year
uh they feel like a team that if things
shake out the right way that's a very
tough division but they're they're gonna
be a scrappy team they were in a lot of
games uh they were scrappy towards the
end of the year and then
ah here's one that that will probably be
people's disagree with how about the
dolphins
how about the dolphins
tom brady's gone from new england the
dolphins were were in a lot of games
they they hung in there we don't know
what two is gonna be
but they did you know they had a lot of
first-round draft picks a lot of draft
capital uh that division feels like it
could be changing a little bit
i you know why not let's throw it out
there the only other one i see that i
could think of is uh is the chargers but
i don't maybe maybe the one thing that
you could say for the chargers benefit
is that playing in front of no fans
they're used to that so
uh they'll be ready to go
my first pass through the eight
divisions of the nfl resulted in a a
knee-jerk reaction that none of these
teams is going to turn it around now all
right i've been locked down
i know i know i locked onto the dolphins
frank gore the jets running back who's
played for the dolphins and the bills
now the jets said yesterday it's wide
open because tom brady's gone and he's
right now look i don't know how wide
open it really is and there are some
people that think the bills are the odds
on favorites to win it but i i don't
rule the dolphins out in the afc east i
the the cardinals i initially brushed
past because you've got the 49ers the
seahawks and the rams in front of them
but but they did beat the seahawks in
seattle late in the season if i recall
correctly they gave the 49ers everything
they could handle not once but twice
last year the defense needed didn't need
to get a whole lot better kyle murray i
think is going to be
the fourth straight second year breakout
quarterback it was carson wentz in 2017.
mahomes in 18 lamar jackson last year
and i think like calamari is going to
have a huge step up this year that i'm
not going to rule them out either
and i somehow keep forgetting this mic i
have to remind myself like every two
weeks
the cardinals have deandre hopkins like
i need to keep saying that to myself the
cardinals have deandre hopkins it
slipped into that time space continuum
where it feels like it never happened
because we had so much you know go on in
life afterwards the cardinals have
deandre hopkins week one will start and
i'll be like wait the cardinals have
deandre hopkins that's a big deal they
have a good receiving core and they have
kyler murray who's going to make that
leap so yeah that will be my dark horse
uh team that could go from worst to
first
the only tangible reminder that i ever
encounter that deandre hopkins is now
with the cardinals comes in reverse any
time you see any betting prop related to
the texans the odds have skyrocketed
since the deandre hopkins trade you take
hopkins off that team and the perception
is they got nothing else now they still
have deshaun watson but who's he going
to throw it to and and so we've seen
their odds get longer to win the
division to make the playoffs to do
anything in 2020.
one last one and we we joke but the
lions season their their their record is
not indicative to what how they were
playing when matthew stafford went out
so that's not a three and 12 team
that could be interesting especially
with do you see what the packers did in
the draft who knows what's going to
happen with the bears and the vikings
you know the vikings can be had they're
not going to be juggernauts so that
could be an interesting one as well
leads to the next question from at
tuesday maxine realistically how do your
chicago bears bounce back in the nfc
north from last year you have the
packers sadly still at the top tuesday
maxine is revealing his bias even though
they didn't add much they also didn't
lose anyone the lions could be better
the vikings of the vikings someone is
going to be the surprise team out who do
you think and how do you think the bears
can climb back to the top of the
division
i think it's pretty easy it's just
getting average quarterback play because
that defense was still good last year
they had a few games where they gave up
i mean i think i i'm trying to remember
exactly what the point total was but it
was like maybe 24 or 28 points to the
packers combined in the two games so
like those are games that if you have
average quarterback play you could win
those games so they were in games
because of their defense if their if
their offense could just get
just a touch better they're going to be
back in the hunt for the nfc north i
really do believe that because their
defense is that good and they haven't
lost a lot of guys and you know akeem
hicks got injured last year which is a
huge deal when you look at you know how
they play defense and just having nick
foles let's see if nick foles can be
that you know average to every now and
then above average that makes a world of
difference yeah you know that first game
of the season bears packers was almost
unwatchable because of the lack of
offense and but for that kind of look
what i found throw by aaron rodgers to
jimmy graham the bears may have won that
game and i'm with you if they can
stabilize the quarterback position if
nick foles can be
and you know we've established he's got
that huge up and down roller coaster
career but he's with matt nagy again if
he can get on that upswing the bears i
think could be a lot better than they
were last year all right uh you could
you can look at it here's here it is
real quick mike they lost the game where
they gave up 10 points they lost a game
where they gave up 17 points twice and
they lost the game where they gave up uh
21 points twice so that's not like they
weren't getting smoked by these teams it
was just the offense was that bad
at iconed would you rather pay dak
prescott 35 million dollars per year or
russell wilson 45 million per year
russell wilson 45 no doubter not even a
question to me yeah wow wow yeah
he's special i there's not
the list of special guys in the nfl
at this point
it might just be patrick mahomes and
russell wilson
deshawn watson you wouldn't put him in
there kyle murray he's going to call him
ours joe and delmar 45 million now 45
million and who
lamar jackson lamar
i would like to see it one more year
i'm saying 45 million
lamar jackson paid 40 million i'd pay
lamar jackson more than jack prescott
obviously i'm saying that
i'm saying the level of
i wouldn't even think you just named the
number i'll give you that patrick holmes
and russell wilson
yeah um i i don't disagree that that
those two would be on and i just i just
think that that there's got to be
somebody else and it may be kyle murray
by the time it's all said and done uh
but i agree with you if i had to choose
between the two and i don't like the
choice
um i'd go russell wilson 45 million a
year but here's the reality dax getting
the 35 million he's going to make 69
over the next two years under the
franchise tag the only way he's trading
that in is to get to 35 million a year
on a long-term deal all right at jr the
boss man what will be the market for
josh gordon in the event he's reinstated
we reported yesterday that even though
gordon has not yet officially applied
for reinstatement he will be doing so
soon with the goal of being on a team
for training camp and he's an
unrestricted free agent his contract
with the seahawks has expired he can
sign with anyone
what do you think his market will be if
and when he gets a a a clearance to
return to the nfl big cap
someone will take a chance right
i mean someone will take a chance
someone will at least bring him in
because
i i'm actually i'm going to pivot here
real quick mike
is antonio brown going to get another
shot because i think that's another one
another case of someone will will take a
shot eventually and just say hey
let's see if this works let's let's take
another run at this because if the guy
can play
we don't really care about everything
else because that's really the reality
of the nfl
here's a problem for antonio brown he's
got three open personal conduct policy
investigations that we know of that for
whatever reason and look i i think that
that one thing the nfl players
association should do when it comes to
the personal conduct policy is put clear
timetables in there clear guidelines and
deadlines so you just can't squat on one
of these investigations for months and i
understand it doesn't really matter
right now because it's not like antonio
brown is missing anything but just this
perception that they just put it in the
cold case file and let it sit there
until they have to deal with it i i
think it's not fair to the players
collectively that they have that power
there was the lawsuit for
sexual assault and rape that was filed
september of last year that
investigation is still open and
unresolved there was the question of
whether or not he sent hostile text
messages threatening text messages to
someone else who came forward in an
article for sports illustrated that
investigation still open and then
earlier this year the incident with the
guy who was driving the moving truck
there's been no word of anything being
done on that so i think that josh gordon
has a much greater chance of getting
back in big cat because the alton's myth
reinstatement tells me the nfl is trying
to find a way to give these guys who
have been suspended for off-field
misconduct related to drug use trying to
give them a clean slate and let them get
back in now that the substance abuse
policy has taken suspensions pretty much
off the table okay good answer yeah i
mean that definitely changes it compared
to josh gordon so i i do still think
someone will take a shot at josh gordon
at kbrand 6767 is there anybody happier
right now than bill belichick because he
won't have to shake hands at the end of
a game
that's a great one that is a great one
very astute yeah what although
i don't know i think you have not left
your compound in west virginia uh but i
have i have left my apartment in
brooklyn and every now and then i've
i've come across someone that i've had
to talk to and the
uh deciding what to do whether it's
nothing or the elbows
brings its own issues we need to have
someone needs to mandate exactly how
we're going to go forward with this is
it elbows is it feet is it no no no
contact just tell me what to do so i
don't have that awkward back and forth
of okay so we don't shake hands we don't
you know what are we doing here
i've got no problem with the subtle nod
of recognition that's my preferred
greeting you just give it a quick hey
how are you you don't have to touch
anybody nobody's touching you what what
do it again do that again
well it's not natural because you have
to i have to be in the settings
yeah that's see italian in you comes out
that looks like you want to
yeah yeah
well i may i mean just because you shake
somebody's hand doesn't mean you don't
want to punch him with the other fist
all right um
but but look we are rocketing toward a
return to normalcy whether it's
advisable or not that's not for me to
decide but football will happen i am
convinced of that
and yeah there's i think it'll be a nod
of recognition not quite at midfield
maybe they'll just kind of go a few
steps out quick nod hello wave and
everybody heads to the locker room and
and look bill belichick's got to be
concerned about this he's pushing 70.
he's in the risk group so all the more
reasons for him to avoid people if he
can last question and this is a very
important one
is there any chance that coach doug's i
didn't know he had his own twitter
handle will make the move to the nfl and
what would be some likely landing spots
for doug duggerton
no chance no chance i like uh coaching
coaching young men making them into
adults i like the molding process and i
also like being able to pay my players
under the table so no chance
and escape every year for a new program
correct how do you decide how do you
decide what what doug duggerton's next
school is going to be
they give you the offers so you go into
the coaching carousel and they tell you
what jobs are open so it's not like you
can just pick any job
so how many do you have to choose from
like when you pick tennessee what were
the other choices 15 georgia tennessee
cal utah
are you trying to like specifically
choose different conferences and kind of
like barnes storm the college football
landscape that way
that is intentional i like i like
getting into different rivalries in
different conferences
how different are the teams in this game
like is it a dramatic difference when
you go from one school to the next and
you have to relearn everything play
books no that stuff oh i bring my
playbook with me come on i have my
philosophy it's go go go
all right i'm
i'm i you probably don't even know this
person's name how mommy i am he ain't i
know how mommy i know how to model i
know a lot of things you don't know a
lot of things thanks thanks a lot i
appreciate you very much i thank thank
you this is you know this is a con we're
trying to have a happy day today it's
the unofficial start of summer it's a
long weekend we're trying to give people
some normalcy i guess this is normalcy
you being a rude ass is normal all right
this is adorable take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports